what's up guys it's
a beautiful day here in
vancouver well actually not so beautiful
it's kind of cloudy
[Music]
today we are going to macau
sorry mikael's showroom
mikhail is um i've been working with him
for a little while he is the owner of
a stucco company here in vancouver their
stucco products are
really really beautiful like i never
really gave a
second thought to stucco but their work
is kind of like
it's artisanal work it's used more for
decorative purposes he initially hired
me to do
some photography work for them
um he really liked the series of photos
that i did
in venice
[Music]
my they just recently got a new showroom
in surrey so i'm gonna go and see if i
can do some
interior design work for them
he's a interesting character
he hates uh minimalism i i love
minimalism but i don't like white color
why don't you like white color you're
actually doing it right
i don't i do like white color but when i
look and design
and there is only white color everywhere
that's not minimalistic design to me
it's like white it's like when you go to
someone's house and
everything's white i didn't even know
you can touch it like
you know like you feel it's like too cl
like too clean it's like it's very safe
for a designer that's what i think
they play safe they're scared of colors
[Music]
so here is the space it's around 25
by 15 feet
it's a small space and you can see
they've already put the lights in so
we'll
have to work with that
[Music]
hey guys so i just got back from the
showroom
and i think it's going to be a fun
little project
we threw out a lot of ideas there uh
mikael had a lot of ideas
and i think the challenge is gonna be to
uh it's a really small room it's a 15 by
23
and they have so many different
uh products um in different textures
and each product has like 10 to 20
different colors
so the challenge is going to be to
categorize them
and showcase them in a way that
is unified and that
is not overwhelming when you walk into
the store
um and then the other challenge is like
actually using the room
and using the walls of the room to your
advantage to showcase all the different
possibilities of the product
so these are the two options that we
came up with
so one of them we have like different
finishes on each wall so this one we
have
the lighter base stone this one we have
metallic
this one is like the concrete looking
texture and this is
um gray micro cement flooring that
carries all the way to to this wall
and this wall is the wall with like the
the glass doors oh yeah and we're gonna
also do
like a little custom made table and then
the other option is dividing everything
into colors because that's the first
thing that you notice when you walk into
the space
so in this instance we looked at
dividing
this wall and this wall into three
different sections
and each section would be a different
color
and the samples displayed
on that section for example these set of
samples will be
in the oxidization finish and these set
of samples would be in the mineral
plaster
finish and on that wall
we would have just the metallics
in each color and so this is the
beige oxidization this is the beige
mineral plaster this is the beige
metallics
and you can still have like variations
of that beige
so you can fit in probably like an
orange
a yellow or a nude color in there and
then
in here you can get some grays
uh maybe some greens and blues yeah so
those are the two
options we're looking at i'm gonna try
to record the whole process
of this project and it's super exciting
because they're totally cool with me
um filming for this vlog
and they've actually even hired me to do
the time lapse
for their own marketing purposes so if
you want to see
the process and the finished product
subscribe
like see you in the next video
[Music]
you